あと30分で東京に行かなきゃいけないんで
ちょっと回していきましょう
はい！こちらに
ハッピーキッチンデコレーションケーキっていうやつがあるんですけど
ほら、あの、よくあるあれさ
あの
知育菓子ですよ。
気軽に作れる、そのお菓子なんですけど
なんとですね
ケーキを作れる知育菓子でございます
わっ！
ほら！刮目しろ
デコレーションケーキ！
水だけで作れるってこうね…
ちょ、説明がいろいろ長ったらしいんですけども
これで、ケーキがこんなちっちゃいの1個作れるんなら
ここに今11個あるんですけど
11個もあればね、まあ普通のこのお店で売ってるような
あの、ほらわかるっしょ？
このパティシエールな、パティシエールな感じのちゃんとしたケーキが作れるんじゃないかと思ってー
やってみよう！
めんどくさい中身が！
あ、いなくなった！
よし、中身がこんだけです。
これめっちゃしんどいわー
マジで言ってんの？これー
おいおいおい。マジかマジかー！
かなりやべえ
中身がかなり多いとです。
まずはースポンジケーキを作ろう
トレーの星に大きいケーキの素を入れます
なるほど
大きいケーキの素と小さいケーキの素でこう2段重ねにするわけね。
こっち(右)が大きいケーキでこっち(左)が小さいスポンジケーキ
こっちが大きいスポンジケーキでこっちが小さいスポンジケーキでいきます
よっしゃ！
三角カップに…大きい方に水2杯、小さい方に水1杯ってことは
こっち(右)に22杯こっち(左)に11杯ってことか
しんど…
22杯とか超しんどい
ちょっ…ちょっとパパッと行ってきます。
はい、というわけで大きい方も小さい方も水を適量入れてきました。
さぁて問題はここからだ！
トレーの底を平らなところで10回くらいトントンと叩いて少し空気を抜きます
なるほどなるほど
こういう感じかね
これ混ぜたほうがいいんじゃね？
混ぜたほうがいいやん
うわーっ！
よし
で、こっち(右)を10回トントンしてる間にこっち(左)も
ただのバカみたいじゃんこれw
はいオッケーです！
じゃあこれを今からレンジで約1分温めます
ファイチャー！！
おぉ、いい感じでございます
はい。
じゃあスポンジケーキがこう冷ますのを待ってる間にもう次に行きましょう
いちごゼリーを作ろうってことでね
は、これめんどくさ
いちごゼリーはいいや
はいじゃあ次にもうクリームを作ります。クリーム。
まずバニラクリームを作ります
おいまた三角カップかよー
どんだけ三角カップ使うん？
え、これ…ちょ、やるしかねえや
やるしか…
ちょっ、水を22杯入れてきます
オッケー。水を22杯入れてきました。
これにバニラクリームの素を全部入れればいいんだよね？
は？いちごクリームもあんの？
冗談きついわ
知育菓子ぃ？もういじめの域だよ。
こんなめんどくさいの作んのか今の子供
すごいなぁ
わ、ちょ、やばくね？
ちょっとオーバードライブしそう
ダメだこれコップ一杯になっちゃうよー
てかもうよくねこれで
はい、クリーム完成でございます。
すまんねだいぶ省いたけど
そろそろちょっとケーキを召喚しよう。
まあ、これでケーキがちゃんとしてればオールオッケーなんだけど
じゃあケーキ取ります
あれ、柔らかくね？これ
これ絶対柔らかい。
あーヤバい…あ、でも意外と
あーダメだ
あ、でもこっちは固いぞよ
ほら、ね？
ケーキといえばケーキでしょ？
ね？
ほら
うん
はい
じゃあこのケーキにクリームをちょっと塗っていきましょう
ドロドロだ！
ちょっと待て
おいおいおいヤバい
あと、トッピングにチョコをぶっかけときましょう
できたぁーーー！！！！！
まあ、かなりね、こう…ケーキとは呼びにくい代物に…
はい！というわけで
かなりねいろいろ過程を省きつつできたんですけども
ものが大きいとやっぱプルプルしちゃって
なんかケーキじゃないただの、なんか…ただの汚いものみたいな
味がおいしければすべて良し！ということでね
早速イーティングしようと思いまーす
ｲｪｰｰｰｰｰｰｰｲ！！！！！！！！
ああ、味もダメだわ。